Sáng hai mấy năm tháng 12, thức tiên từ phòng kính sát hình sự công an nghệ ANSOMIET,
lưng vì vừa chết phá, oi nhóm một bản vụ khi quan dụ trên không giảm mạc.
Bất đầu bắt sử bố miệ hài đối tượng, đây là chuyên ANL nhất từ trước đến nay,
lyd quan tới chế tạo, một bản tàng chữ vụ khi quan dụng trái phép, mạc công an nghệ ANSYESOA.
Pòi chính già xuất sắp mình từ quan thong ANFRIED một số đối tượng trên đẹp bản nghệ ANN,
một vụ khi quan dụ của một đường dây một bản vụ khi có tính chất trên nghiệp,
thật quan một cháng mạc xấu với quy mô đặc biệt lớn, lyd quan đến nhiều địa bản trên cả nước.
Bản chuyên ANSYESOA, lịch đường dây bố bản vụ khi nay, zò hai đối tượng,
là lấy thành hơn, sinh năm 1877, trù sả sân tịch tình quảng ái,
và sâm thiết thơm, sinh năm 1870, trù sả hương lòng thành phố Chí Minh, điều hành.
Để vận hành đường dây, hai đối tượng trên, linh hệ và mốc nối với nhau,
mối đối tượng phụ trách một số khóc nhau trong sẩm xuất mua bản cáo lại vụ khi,
sau đó các đối tượng, tạo tài hoàn mắc tin giả, sau bán chế cựng dụng mạng sã hội
và các trang mạng khác để giới thiệu sản phẩm.
Mọi gia hai đối tượng trên cũng trực tiếp mua bản vụ khi với những đối tượng,
có như cầu liên hệ trực tiếp.
Từng ngày 12, tháng 12, ngày 12, ngày 12, ngày 12, ngày 12, ngày 12, ngày 12, ngày 12, ngày 12,
lấy đặc quan tình nghĩ ANS, chỉ đạo phòng cây xát hình sử,
đâm rặt trên khai hành trục tổ công tác, trù chỉ phối hợp với các phòng nghiệp phụ công ANTình,
cộng ANS đã thay hoàn, cộng ANS một số phường sẽ trên đẹp bàn tình như ANS
và cộng ANS đã đơn vị đẹp phương trên cả nước,
tính hành bắt, khám sét hình cấp 1,5 đối tượng ở nhiều tình thành phố khác nhau,
tăng và tu dữ gồm sống mi tư khổ xuống quân dụ,
2,5% 2,5% thuộc sánh mục vũ khí quân dụ,
2,5% khổ xuống là công cụ hỗ trợ,
1,5% sống người về đạc mi và đạc cao su,
2 lắp phóc 1,5 tích bị dạo và các đồ vật khác, có liên quán,
con cứ cơ tài liệu thu thập được phòng cải sát hình sự công an tình đã giá quyết định
hợi tổ vụ ANN, hợi tổ và mấy tả Mỹ cán về tổ,
chỉ tạm tăng chữ vận chuyển sự dụ, buồ bàn trái phép, khoảng 7 vật bụ khi quân dụ,
phương tệ tỷ thật quân dự, đồng thời tiếp tục tập trông lấu tranh mở giọng trên án.